Continuing where we left off yesterday
morning
in the chapter regarding the rulings
and rules of wiping over footwear when
making wudu
instead
of washing the feet.
We left off with the statement of
al-Hasan al-Basri rahimahullah as
articulated by al-Nawawi in his book
al-Minhaj fi sharhi
Muslim ibn al-Hajjaj.
He says
[Silence]
al-Hasan al-Basri says, "I have been
directly told by 70
of the Messenger of Allah's companions
radiyallahu anhum and sallallahu alayhi
wasallam that the Messenger of Allah
would consistent- consistently and
practiced wiping over his footwear."
[Silence]
And
there's a narration here that the author
mentions, the narration of Jarir ibn
Abdillah al-Bajali radiyallahu anhu
who was amongst his companions of the
Tabi'in. Jarir ibn Abdillah is a
companion, and he was amongst some the
second generation.
And he relieved himself, and then he
made wudu and wiped over his
leather footwear.
And so they asked him about this. They
said,
"This is a practice that you employ?"
He said, "Yes. I I saw myself the
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam do exactly this."
And so
this is
a critical narration for a number of
reasons.
Number one, Jarir ibn Abdullah
is someone who accepted Islam way later.
Surat al-Ma'idah
was revealed
during Hajjatul Wada'.
In Hajj.
So,
in the
12th month
of
the 10th year
after Hijrah
was
Hajjatul Wada'.
And
Surat al-Ma'idah was revealed then. Now,
the ayah, the verse mentioning wudu
and also hinting and mentioning outright
wiping over the footwear
is in Surat al-Ma'idah. And if Jarir ibn
Abdullah accepted Islam
after the revelation of Surat
al-Ma'idah, meaning very, very late,
this means that this is
the last
of its rulings that the Prophet salla
[Arabic recitation]
Alayhis salatu was salam.
Another important point is that this is
considered a Umdah.
It is considered a major reference
upon which
the Iraqi Madhhab, the Madhhab of Ahlul
Iraq, and later
would
be refined into the Madhhab of Abi
Hanifah Rahimahullah.
It hinges on this narration in this
topic, which is important because Jarir
was there when Ahlul Iraq
and it was narrated from him by
Al-A'mash
an Ibrahim an Hammam.
Another issue here
is that
you read this narration and at first
glance it seems strange, right? Because
[Arabic recitation]
Anhu, he's
sitting amongst his companions.
He relieves himself, he goes and
relieves himself, he comes back, he
makes wudu, they're watching him. This
is a companion of the prophet Sallallahu
Alaihe Wasallam, they're learning
from him whatever he saw or learned
directly from the messenger, and they
see him
instead of taking off his footwear and
washing his feet, they watch him as he
wipes over
his
leather footwear.
And so they ask him Taf'alu Hadha? Is
this something that you practice
consistently?
Which seems strange, right? You would
think that everybody knows that. This is
common knowledge. No, not necessarily.
Because remember, narrations
how do they work? I mean, imagine right
now, is this all of the community of
Tucson in this masjid right now?
No.
And so, if I were to speak about
something, who's here to see it? You
guys.
And then, whoever you incidentally
happen to tell along the way of what I
said. How long would it take for
something that I say
to resonate through all of the
community? Could take generations.
Could take an entire generation for it
to reach organically every single
person.
Right? That's how narrations work. It
wasn't every companion knows every
narration immediately as soon as he says
it. No.
Neither is it that every companion knows
every verse of the Quran immediately as
soon as it's revealed, as well know.
Especially taking into account that
people were traveling, they were coming
and going, people that
left Medina, they came back, they
find that it had changed. people who
when they left the prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was alive and well, when
they came back he had passed away. And
major other companions has had pushed
off towards Yemen, had pushed off
towards
the
Iraqi front, the eastern front, and the
western front.
And so, if we take all of this into
consideration,
we understand
the critical na- nature of the time it
takes for
all narrations to become to the majority
of the scholars, especially at that time
in certain regions.
And so,
this is why they are saying to him,
"Taf'aluna hadha?" They found this was
something new to them or something
strange. Why? Because
it's not something that they had heard
of before,
this time.
[Silence]
And then how do you say the ayah? Tukra.
Al wajhain qira' sab'iyyah
mutawatirah.
[Arabic recitation]
aydiyakum ila l-marafiq wamsahu bi
ru'usikum
[Arabic recitation]
bi nasb
kalimat arjul alladhi huwa jam' li rijl
[Arabic recitation]
fa huwa ma'tuf 'ala aysh?
'ala faghsilu ya'ni faghsilu wujuhakum
waghsilu aydiyakum ila l-marafiq wamsahu
bi ru'usikum waghsilu arjulakum ila
l-ka'bayn
[Arabic recitation]
fi qira' sab'iyyah
yaqulu
[Arabic recitation]
you will see come
the job
for either Corey imagine one
kind of my to fun Allah one second
B
be you will see come
for your corner talk to you and I
for you will do have come what I will
see you I do you come in the matter of
one second be you will see you come
one second B
are you going to come in the cabin
have a B H
be be the job because of a lamb on there
what have I had my alarm and I know
you will know be here
women can laugh at Allah
really here
what I know
that you will know be here
Allah
a religion and more general that
and I you will know how to handle the
religion and more general that what I
know that you will know how to handle
the religion and more general that and I
you will know how to handle the
and so an interesting point is that this
verse in Surat al-Ma'idah the the verse
of wudu
it is recited in two ways. Both
recitations are equal in the sense that
both of them are legitimate recitations
and that is what I do you and
you them
if it is recited what I do you them
with a fat on the lamb
this means to wash the feet
and if it is recited with a custom on
the lamb on the lamb what I do you like
them it means to wipe over the feet
and what's meant by wiping over the feet
wiping over footwear
because all of the agree
that a person does not wipe
the feet.
The bare feet. The bare feet are not
wiped. The bare feet are washed. This is
consensus. This is beyond consensus.
Right?
So, what is wiped about the feet? What
is wiped is the footwear that is on the
feet. So, it's in the Quran. It's in the
verse. It's clearly in the verse.
And these narrations
they go to what? Bolster that and to
articulate the details, to fill in the
blanks, and to fill in some of the
more finer details of the verse.
Now,
one last thing for us to take into
consideration.
We just said that
Al-Ma'idah is the only place that the
ayah of wudu is mentioned. Wudu in its
articulated full form, right?
And we mentioned
that Al-Ma'idah was revealed
when? All the way in the last
3 months of the prophet's life,
salallahu alayhi wasallam.
Cuz he passed away when?
Rabi' al-Awwal, correct?
And so,
that is 4 months. As a matter of fact,
when he stood on Mountain of Arafat and
said and recited Al-Yawm Akmaltu Lakum
Dinakum
on the 9th of Dhul-Hijjah,
he lived 81 days exactly after that. 81
days.
So, if we understand that
and the only place where
where wudu is mentioned in detail is in
Al-Ma'idah,
were the Muslimin making wudu before
this verse was revealed
or
was this verse revealed upon a people
who are already making will do?
Do you understand the question?
No, it's not the same.
Very different.
It's very different.
Because if the verse was revealed and
they were not making will do yet,
that means that when the verse was
revealed, they learned from the verse,
this is what we put into action.
Whereas if they were already making will
do for decades
and then the verse was revealed, now the
verse
it means something different because now
the verse is going to be implemented
based on the actions that they've
already been practicing for many many
years.
That changes a lot in the dynamic of
in the dynamic of the verse. A good
example of this
the mouth and nose.
Is that obligatory or is it preferred in
will do?
Obligatory. Person may say, "Well, it's
not mentioned explicitly in the verse."
Right?
You say, "Okay."
The verse was revealed when?
After they had already been making will
do for years and years.
So that means when the prophet
alayhi wasallam taught them how to make
will do,
he had taught them what? The mouth and
nose and never left that out.
The verse now is revealed reflecting
those teachings already.
And this is not something that's
uncommon.
There are many rulings in Islam that
were practiced and then a verse was
revealed and made that practice a part
of the recitation of the Quran and vice
versa.
Let's ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
you alimana